ein leben auf der venus völlig undenkbar
mit einer durchschnittstemperatur von
rund 460 grad celsius ist es dort nicht
nur heiß genug um blei zu schmelzen
die atmosphäre der venus besteht zudem
auch noch zum größten teil aus
kohlendioxid doch in der vergangenheit
sei die - offensichtlich ganz anders aus
bedeckt mit ozean und somit vielleicht
sogar bewohnbar ein forschungsteam aus
wales hat jetzt herausgefunden warum
sich der planet wohl stück für stück zu
der heutigen höllen landschaft
entwickelt hat ja und da liegen die
gedanken an die aktuelle entwicklung
hier auf der erde ja nicht so fern
allerdings ist der grund für die
entwicklung auf der venus ein ganz
anderer tricks um science-fiction hier
gibt's täglich faszinierende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
das ist wirklich eine kuriose
vorstellung die - mit einer deutlich
kühleren oberfläche als heute und zudem
noch bedeckt von zahlreichen ozean ein
planet also auf dem leben einst sehr gut
vorstellbar wäre genau davon geht jetzt
eine neue studie eines forschungsteams
aus wales aus die nach könnte der planet
tatsächlich eine ganze zeit lang
äusserst lebensfreundliche
umweltbedingungen geboten haben die
venus soll in diesem stadium sogar der
erde ziemlich ähnlich gewesen seien
zusammen mit experten und expertinnen
der nasa und forschungs kolleginnen und
kollegen aus washington führte das team
simulationen an einem numerischen
gezeigten modell durch hierbei wurde vor
allem der einfluss potenzieller ozeane
unterschiedlicher tiefe auf die
rotationsgeschwindigkeit des planeten
unter die lupe genommen wie die
fachleute aus mails jetzt in ihrer
studie schreiben haben die ozeane der
venus damals wie eine art bremse auf die
rotationsgeschwindigkeit des planeten
eingewirkt die vorhandenen ozeane haben
also dafür gesorgt dass sich die drehung
der venus deutlich verlangsamt hat
vereinfacht gesagt ist dies auf die
reibung zurückzuführen die bei flut und
ebbe zwischen einem ozean und dem
meeresboden wirkt dazu matthias green
der an der studie beteiligt war
tatsächlich hätte diese gezeiten bremse
die venus innerhalb von zehn bis 50
millionen jahren von einer rtl
die rotationsgeschwindigkeit auf ihr
heutiges dreht tempo verlangsamen können
diese arbeit zeigt wie wichtig gezeiten
sein können um die rotation eines
planeten zu verändern und wie wichtig
gezeigten sind um einen planeten
bewohnbar zu machen und die folge dieser
gezeigten bremse ist bis heute zu
beobachten die sogenannte retrograden
rotation der venus im klartext heißt das
dass sich der planet im vergleich zu
unserer erde in die entgegengesetzte
richtung drehen doch nicht nur das die
venus dreht sich nicht nur verkehrt
herum sondern auch mit einer sehr
langsamen drehgeschwindigkeit um sich
einmal um sich selbst zu drehen braucht
der planet 2 143 tage genau diese
langsame drehgeschwindigkeit verhindert
jetzt wiederum das flüssige ozeane auf
wir existieren können auch auf der erde
und ihren ozean wirken letztere übrigens
wie eine art bremse auf die rotation
unseres planeten allerdings in einem
wirklich sehr kleinen ausmaß in einer
million jahren wird so ein tag um
lediglich 20 sekunden verlängert
abgesehen von diesen neuen erkenntnissen
macht die studie eine weitere sache
deutlich die venus wurde lange von der
forschung vernachlässigt doch das ändert
sich gerade
schon 2023 möchte die indian space
research organisation die esr einen
orbiter zur venus stammen die nasa
überlegt mit ausgewählten missionen ab
dem jahr 2025 zu folgen und auch die
europäische weltraumorganisation esa und
die russische weltraumagentur roskosmos
haben die venus im visier und das
steigende interesse hat einen grund
nicht wenige experten und expertinnen
sind davon überzeugt dass sie hier eines
der größten rätsel der wissenschaft
lösen können was genau macht einen
planeten bewohnbar und so werden derzeit
mit hochdruck technologien entwickelt
die den schrecklichen bedingungen auf
der venus tropfen könnten falls die
windows aber mit großen
lebensfreundlichen ozean vielleicht
sogar drei milliarden jahre lang
tatsächlich wie die erde aus gesehen hat
ist auch eine sache ganz klar die
evolution hat hier genug zeit in aktion
zu treten
genügend zeit also für die entstehung
von leben und vielleicht haben besonders
hartnäckige organismen sogar bis heute
überleben können dazu der us astronom
dhabi dar warum investieren wir so viel
zeit
die suche nach leben auf dem mars wenn
es dort nur 400 millionen jahre lang
flüssiges wasser gab und dann steht
dagegen die gehen uns mit drei
milliarden jahren wasser und niemand
interessiert sich für sie nicht
auszuschließen also dass die venus sogar
der erste bewohnbare planet im
sonnensystem war dazu der pariser
astronom thomas schünemann
das alles könnte der beginn eines neuen
jahrzehnts der venus sein wird venus die
erde 2.0 terraforming total anklicken
anschauen und raumzeit lockt der zukunft
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran